у нас в студії зараз міністр освіти та
науки України Сергій шкарлет пане Сергію
вітаю Вас
скажіть нам коли очікується рішення щодо
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання або
національного мультиппредметного тесту
яке Верховна Рада має ухвалити і всі
чекають що ж 11-класники цього року
складатимуть Дуже дякую за запитання як
завжди Дякую за питання за увагу до
освіти адже ми завжди говоримо що якщо
ми звертаємо увагу на освіту то це Ми
формуємо наше майбутнє Звісно що
сьогодні більше за всіх і батьків і
випускників сьогодні в принципі
цікавлять питання Яким чином буде
відбуватися вступ 23-му році
на сьогодні ситуація така що єдиним
основним до цього часу інструментом
вступу є зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання
згідно діючого законодавства
ми ще в вересні місяці як Міністерство
сформували необхідні накази необхідну
процедуру сформували всі абсолютно
додатки для проведення вступу в 23-му
році але при цьому Ми чітко розуміли що
маємо дати альтернативу оскільки
розуміли що війна Може
затягнутися хоча наші збройні сили щодня
його наближують нашу перемогу при цьому
Ми маємо дати альтернативу вступу саме
національний мультипрідний тест який в
принципі схожий на минулорічний Але дещо
з певними особливостями в кінці
листопада на початку грудня Міністерство
освіти вивісило на громадське
обговорення проект моделі вступу на 2023
рік
і в цьому контексті в принципі на
сьогодні з усіма зацікавленими сторонами
є певний суспільний діалог є певна
суспільна узгоджена позиція щодо моделей
вступу до нас до правил
прийому до умов вступу на Громадському
обговоренні надійшло майже 300
пропозицій більш того ми проводили
декілька таких діалогів з народними
депутатами з
громадськими експертами з батьками нас
велика аудиторія батьки соус які
постійно нам дають певні певні поради
певне бачення ззовні Як це має проходити
для дітей для випускників
суспільний діалог в принципі Ми сьогодні
завершили модель вступу є і сподіваюсь
що найближчим чином Верховна Рада прийме
цей самий модель вступу адже
розраховуємо 7-8 сесія Можливо навіть на
7-8 лютого ми будемо мати якісь
результати знаю що комітет Ми з головою
комітету своїм обоком говорили
поставлено на питання саме підтриманий
Урядовий законопроект по моделі вступу
на 2023 рік і очікуємо найближчим чином
прийняття саме як закону Тобто можна уже
розраховуватись здебільшого і батькам І
випускникам що буде національний
мультипредметний тест 2023 році чим він
принципово відрізнятиметься від
минулорічного і яку модель взагалі
пропонує Міністерство
Дуже дякую за запитання ну це не тільки
Міністерство це суспільний діалог який з
громадськими експертами з батьками з
депутатами з фахівцями Міністерства з
фахівцями з українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти якраз таки
відбувся він буде дуже національний
мультипрем'єрний тест 23-му році буде в
принципі дуже схожий на минулорічний але
при цьому окрім обов'язкових предметів
ми будемо мати ще і модель предмету на
вибір саме вступника який може бути
окрім української мови та математики
Може обрати історію України може обрати
фізику може обрати хімію може обрати
біологію може обрати одну з іноземних
мов для вступу тобто Висловити свої
прагнення і своє бажання того як у кого
більше набрати певну кількість балів за
проходження МТ історія України не буде
обов'язковим предметом Наскільки я
розумію за тою моделлю яка зараз
пропонується А чому чому вирішили її
прибрати з цього обов'язкового переліку
знову ж таки скажу що це був певний
суспільний діалог і суспільне
домовленість адже Міністерство коли
виставляло в кінець листопада на початок
грудня умови прийому ми пропонували три
обов'язкових дисципліни в яку включались
історію України яку включалась
українська мова і математика але
четвертий мав бути на вибір але маючи
діалог з громадськими експертами з
особливо з батьками ми чітко розуміли що
безпека в ситуації і кількість часу на
складання цього тесту все-таки більше
схиляє нас до того моменту що ми маємо
три предмети поставити але при цьому
діти по-різному намагалися готуватись до
спеціалізації того або іншого обраного
закладу вищої освіти і в тому контексті
хтось кращий готував іноземну мову хтось
дійсно готувався до історії України
хтось кращий готувався на хімію біологію
і в цьому контексті ми в суспільному
діалозі в тому числі і з батьками
врахували той той факт що дітям треба
дати можливість вибору Я дуже сподіваюсь
що саме беручи приклад з минулого року
ми наші вступники будуть активно
використовувати в переліку тих наборів
саме історію України для складання
національного мультику предметного тесту
в цьому році одразу скажу що
Які би не обрав набір предметів для
вступу кожен з випускників кожен за
клієнтів він може він бути буде мати
право вступати на будь-яку спеціальність
будь-якого закладу вищої освіти єдине
будуть встановлені певні вагові
коефіцієнти наприклад там медичні
університети звісно хімія біологія е-е
можливо гуманітарні там можливо буде
історію України або іноземна мова або
інші
наприклад фізики України Це ж діти її як
я думаю вивчають не для того щоб
пам'ятати коли була битва при Жовтих
Водах це такий предмет який формує твою
державницьку самосвідомість коли я
складала ЗНО це був перший рік цю ЗНО і
історії України зробили обов'язковим
тоді предметом якби цього не сталося я
не впевнена що я так добре ви почала
вчити історію України Це дуже багато
мені потім в житті дало знаєте це був
предмет такий і зірочку факультативний і
коли ми прибираємо історію України як
обов'язковий предмет то чи не обкрадаємо
ми себе тоді
м-м ви знаєте Дуже гарне запитання якщо
ми вчимо історію України як зірочкою
повністю поділяю в тому що ти маєш знати
особливо в тих умовах які ідуть зараз
історію своєї держави і тим більше
держави на яку здійснюється
повномасштабна агресія нашого північного
сусіда в тому контексті тут вони не може
бути зірочкою це і свідомість батьків
свідомість мене як громадянина цієї
країни тут не може бути примусу не може
бути історія як ну об'єктивно її
насаджувати у робити обов'язково це моя
свідома позиція громадянина має бути
знати історію своєї держави і Незалежно
від того чи є вона обов'язково предметом
чи вона є предметом за виміром історію
як мене як патріоти України як
державника України як як людина яка
збирається жить в Україні ну навіть
самому маленького віку Вона має бути
апріорі вивчена має бути дитина людина
громадянин її знати незалежно від
зірочки незалежно від обов'язку
складати в ЗНО або ммт в цьому контексті
об'єктивно є багато людей які не
складають ні ЗНО на нмте але це ж
взагалі не означає що якщо немає
обов'язково в історії не треба знати і
обов'язково треба знати Ну просто ви
розуміли це підштовхує тебе до більшої
роботи на цій території ще більше до
знання історії до патріотизму і до
відданості своєї держави незалежно від
того іспити це чи не іспит ви сказали
про те що ммт 2023 буде схожим на те що
відбувалося 22-му році але тоді влітку і
на початку осені ми не мали такого
виклику із відключеннями електроенергії
як
цієї цього літа Цієї осені якщо проблема
збережеться вєлою відключення
продовжиться як складати нмт як
відбувається онлайн
Дуже гарне запитання адже це знов таки
великий виклик війні великий виклик тому
що позбути наших дітей права до вступу
права на освіту але ми системно
готувались разом з головами військових
адміністрацій разом з навчальними
закладами Це сьогодні є пункти в яких
центри тестування в яких будуть
проводитися з ммт або ЗНО вони обладнані
генераторами вони ми на сьогодні разом з
партнерами домовились про більше ніж 100
000 електронних девайсів які роздаємо 70
тисяч ми вже роздали викладачами вже
роздали
в заклади освіти адже ноутбуки при
наявності генератора або стерлінка вони
досить довго тримають сучасні девайси
досить довго тримають
заряд тримають без додаткової
електроенергії в тому контексті ми ще
передбачили якщо станеться така ситуація
що надовго не буде світла буде
можливість складати дітям в додаткову
сесію я в цьому контексті абсолютно
впевнений ми зможемо
забезпечити нашим дітям гідні умови
вступу так як само ми зробили в минулому
році і не тільки в Україні а і за межами
нашої держави адже наші партнери і в
цьому році підтвердили принаймні ті
країни це 32 країни 56 міст по всьому
світу в яких проводилися
нмт Минулого року також підтвердили ми
ще сподіваємось також на розширення цієї
географії по вступу ммт в інших країнах
для забезпечення права на навчання саме
в Україні випускників в минулому році ми
отримали майже рекордну кількість
вступників за всі роки незалежності
більше ніж 622 000 наших українських
дітей вступили до саме До закладів
освіти України із основною метою зміни
моделі вступу в 2022 так само як
сьогодні пропонується модель на 23-й рік
Саме основне завдання було в тому щоб
діти обрали українські заклади освіти і
навчалися в Україні адже діти - це те
джерело ті патріоти які будуть
відновлювати нашу державу після перемоги
довше діти залишаються за кордоном
особливо якщо вік такий що скоро
вступати в університет тим вищі Ризик що
там вони залишаться отримувати вищу
освіту як зробити так як аби вони
повернулися сюди і подавали документи
навіть перебуваючи за кордоном в
українській вище сьогодні немає ніякої
обов'язкової вимоги до моменту навчання
повернутися до України для того щоб
подати документи в квітні місяці буде
відкритий абсолютно
відкрита модель і Відкритий доступ до
реєстрації на нмт або ЗНО До закладів
вищої освіти це буде можна буде робити
абсолютно в онлайн форматі в тому числі
не тільки для дітей які перебувають в
країнах Європейського Союзу інших
країнах світу Ми навіть забезпечили в
минулому році в цьому році буде
забезпечена навіть ті хто на тимчасово
окупованих територіях проживає і бажає
навчатися в закладах освіти України
таких дітей на тимчасово окупованих
територіях майже 74 000 на сьогодні
навчається в закладах освіти українських
за українською програмою і прагнуть у
навчатися і далі за українськими
стандартами
окупованих територій було все менше а
потім вони взагалі зникли як явище дякую
вам дуже за те що сьогодні прийшли до
нашої студії Сергій шкарлет міністр
освіти та науки України долучився до
марафону єдині новини зараз буде коротка
пауза Після якої випуск новин